in any case
the part of the problem is that our our
current environment now
allows arbitrarily large numbers of
people to compile their sense of what is
taking place
in real time you know people are on
twitter and elsewhere discussing what is
taking place as it happens as somebody
says something the interpretation of
what they meant unfolds
immediately and that that's very
corrosive
to the normal process of having a bunch
of different opinions about what was
said and what it meant
and what that implies going forward
which would then force a discussion that
would be at some level interesting we
skipped the discussion
and went straight to the knee-jerk
interpretation in this case maybe it's
two knee-jerk interpretations depending
upon
uh you know which twitter you're paying
attention to
right what do you mean which twitter
well presumably there are two
for americans there are two twitters
right there's
i mean and you actually stumbled across
this line earlier this week
where where somebody else stumbled
across it into you
right somebody who lives
over in democrat twitter right
posts at some point she's now deleted it
but she says
oh my god i stumbled into a large number
of people who think this woke stuff is
off the rails
who are they no no not just thatch what
she says so this is um
yeah this is interesting actually right
so she
a she's got a vested interest in in
keeping
critical race theory alive because what
her business appears to be
is running dei diversity equity
inclusion trainings
and she tweets we just lost our well
there's a couple of them we just lost
our first client to trump's order to
to forbid uh critical race theory
training in
federal organizations um you know i i
know i'm on the right side of the
history but i fear you know i fear this
being at the end something like this
um and then she says
i'm running across a cohort of people
that seems to be thousands strong and
it's a lot stronger than that but seems
to be thousands strong
who detest crt but also seem to be
anti-trump
who are these people right right and so
many people myself included responded
and said
yes we're here and we're reasonable and
we're all across the political spectrum
but yes some of us
are indeed democrats and always have
been and can't promise we always will be
but
um you know this this is true and
please you know please would you would
you listen would you be up for a
conversation i actually specifically
invited her to
to talk if she was willing and she
deleted the tweet
so and that i would point out is a
perfect analog for what happened
throughout the evergreen
riots where progress could be made with
an individual very briefly but it wasn't
durable
because they would get pulled back to
something yeah right so anyway
tragic that she sort of discovered
this land of people that didn't fit what
she'd been told the enemy looked like
and then basically burned the bridge i
mean
it's metaphorical but almost literally
yeah burned the bridge so she couldn't
get back there
her original the original missive on
twitter you know and it's a ridiculous
platform but
um seemed to suggest a curiosity
yeah a super an actual genuine surprise
and an openness because
she had presumably been in one of these
when one of these silos
and really truly believed the you know
the headlines from wapo and the guardian
and the new york times and everything
that if
you oppose critical race theory you are
a white supremacist
those are the same thing and no that's
not true
yeah it reminds me actually of the young
woman
i've described her situation before who
wanted to who sought me out as i left
the
the uh meeting the
nearly violent now quite famous meeting
at the top of the library building at
evergreen
right 2017. sought me out and basically
her point went
when other protesters attempted to
shut down the conversation her point was
no i want to talk to him
and she actually says benjamin boyce
covers this very well on his channel
she actually says he seems okay to me
right i'm talking to him and he doesn't
sound like what you're telling me he is
and then
anyway they recaptured her the following
day well i'm sure she was made to sing
many choruses and start saying spangled
banner and sign many loyalty oats she
was in fact
uh forced to read a statement the
following day
at one of their rallies
you